so we spoke before the break about fox
news in the aftermath of the buffalo
mass shooting terrorist attack bringing
on a guest and john scott pushing on the
guests the idea that i don't know
since video games have become so
realistic and violent we've seen more
violent shootings and we've already
talked about the academic work on the
link between real world violence and
video games and there is no such link
now i want to show you something else
that fox news did in the immediate
aftermath of the buffalo shooting where
it's a
domestic
white guy
born here
allegedly with three weapons went and
targeted black people deliberately went
and targeted black people
fox news hosted a segment uh where they
made the case
that we really need to be worried about
the hispanic terrorists
coming
through the u.s mexico border they we we
just had this incident
and you're talking about something which
is not actually a statistical issue i'll
explain take a listen to this he is not
the secretary of homeland security he's
the secretary of homeland insecurity
because our country by the way this is
tom homan from the heritage foundation
or right wing think tank safe
because like last month they admitted
they arrested 42 people on the screening
database terror screening database there
has been over 700 000 known got away
since joe biden became president how
many of them were on the terrorist
screening database are in the country
right now you're not going to tell me
out of 700 000 161 different countries
many of that
sponsored terrorism not a single person
came across that border not get arrested
that came this country do us harm this
is a national security issue of huge
proportions i've done this for 35 years
lawrence i've never been more concerned
about the safety of this nation than i
am under this administration the
secretary needs to be impeached on day
one when the republicans take back
congress and i told them that last week
when i met with them yeah what a
powerful declaration from tom homan now
let's let's remember
um we know a lot about immigrants to the
united states now is it impossible
they always say you've got muslim
terrorists coming through the border
disguised as hispanics coming here and
doing terror well we know about the
terror attacks here and it's mostly
american-born white men that do the the
terror attacks
in the united states so let's just think
it through
we know that if you take three groups
um american-born individuals
legal immigrants to the united states
and illegal immigrants to the united
states the group that commits crime at
the highest rate is those born here in
the united states now it makes perfect
sense we shouldn't hear that and say
that that doesn't make any sense david
why would it be why would that it seems
that the immigrants should be the ones
committing more crime why
why
if you are here undocumented
you're aware
that any kind of police interaction in
some states where they have shown me
your papers laws
even just
a driving infraction
could end up with you getting deported
you know your status here is
undocumented so you are incentivized not
to be on the radar of law enforcement in
a way that a legal immigrant or a a
natural born american would not be
natural born americans know if i get
caught speeding doesn't matter what
state it's in i'm not getting deported
whereas an undocumented immigrant knows
that that is a possibility that's an
incentive for undocumented immigrants to
actually behave even better and they do
and they do
legal immigrants as well legal
immigrants also commit crime at a lower
rate
than domestic natural born uh citizens
of the united states and it makes
perfect sense so there's like two or
three different layers here one is of
course that they're just wrong about
this idea that the ma the major
committers of crime here are
foreign-born they're not by rate right
okay so that accounts per capita for the
fact that there are more uh uh
natural domestically born individuals in
the country and number two
without a shred of irony an 18-year-old
us-born white guy targets black people
uh kills 10 and uh injures three 11 of
the 13 in total are black
and fox runs with video games or violent
and we've really got to do something
about terrorists coming over the
southern border no they're being born
here
they're being born here so there's sort
of a question as to whether people like
tucker
are going to cool it with some of the
great replacement stuff because it's so
directly linked to the shooting over the
weekend and this is this is the clip i
showed you is from the hard news
side of fox news so it's going to be
quite a scene
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video